one
ah
all right
we are live ladies and gentlemen welcome
to hot breath the show where you learn
comedy from the pros every wednesday on
our youtube channel we do a live q a
with an industry influencer and this is
a guest
that i am super excited about who's
doing a lot for the comedy industry both
in front of and behind the scenes
and i'm excited to learn more about her
story and how comedians can
really start building their own careers
like she's helped so many amazing
comedians do so
honestly there's not much on google
about her so we're really gonna we're
really gonna dive deep on this
but um
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the hot
breath verse the one the only boss lady
nay everyone give it up for the boss
lady
hey
[Laughter]
this is so cool we actually started a
few minutes late because we were
chopping it up and you know my white
people time you know
you know how we be but how are you doing
you look super comfy over there i am
thank you you know hanging out chilling
talking to you i'm excited so thanks for
having me oh my gosh thank you and just
just for context could you give us a
little um
a little of your um
your bio here kind of like who you are
and what you do because i'm familiar
with you through our mutual connections
but if people like google your name
right now there's really
really not that much out there
you know listen
uh my background is pr so if you need my
services i got you
i love it um no well my government
official name natalia strowman
i was raised in atlanta georgia where i
went to a performing arts high school
majored in dance and danced at a
company called total dance in atlanta
out of adamsville so if you ever hear
adamsville area
that's where i'm from because i spent
most of my time
there uh with ballet jazz tap
west african specifically and it
gained me a lot of experience uh
as a performer a bay performer then i
got a scholarship
to groningen state university
for dance so
that's my hbc you love
um
and
i
am from there if you will so i have a
lot of roots in louisiana
one of my clients is growing state i do
booking for them live shows i arrive at
southern universities in baton rouge
louisiana so they're one of my long time
clients as well and i really just do
project management artist management
consulting i started when i was in
brambling my
mass communications degree has a
concentration in public relations
so
i was headed to law school thurgood
marshall law school specifically after i
started my graduate program at brambly i
wanted to go to houston i always wanted
to live in houston so uh before i
actually made it a semester
uh even stepped foot on campus you know
i got a call from my dad is a comedian
earthquake and
he just asked me to come and kind of
stab his business originally you know
how some artists were just having
rebranding um a relaunch and
he didn't have a team at that point
outside of his current agency and i kind
of came out there my brother was very
young at the time he's uh
18 19 now and um it was kind of like
stepping in uh first born daughter when
your dad's not married and i'm the only
one that was kind of raised in this
business being from atlanta we owned a
comedy club uptown comedy corner it's
now um the original uptown you know in
atlanta still today
and uh we did a lot of
uh
weekends in comedy clubs as you can
imagine as a child so uh i've always
grown up with ricky smiley and steve
harvey and
uh being in the business so i've done
everything as a child from take tickets
at a
ticket booth at a comedy club to
counting a room to you know in the bar
to in the green room you know i was kind
of groomed in that so i kind of applied
that and my degree from grambling in
public relations and tried to fit in
where i could with my father already
being a veteran in comedy and we were
able to do a lot of great you know work
and build things that i created and i
wrote a radio show called quake's house
for him and we went to new york
uh for a couple of years that's now on
siriusxm that i did a partnership when i
was managing him
at the time uh with kevin hart's you
know uh
radio siriusxm channel so it was the
first um
real show that they had on the channel
with jeff klein again so that was fun uh
we did that with his agency uh innovated
and
uh after that i think it was probably
like a year i started to branch off and
actually focus in on comedians more my
age my demographic
trying to see what i could um apply all
of that work and knowledge that i got
with managing my dad and from my degree
and
my love of law
and kind of seeing where i fit in right
and that's when i kind of launched boss
lady management group
and i have
chico bean
and junior from the steve harvey morning
show
i have darren big baby brand and tyler
chronicles
um working with a
wonderful new um
i guess you could say improv comedian by
the name of lou young
who is having a sensational time on
instagram i've seen him yeah yeah you
ever get a chance i mean i've been
working with lou for probably like a
year right before uh pandemic and uh we
really
uh nestled in and my uh favorites uh
i'll say because i can say this because
he's grandfam uh black ron
who is my breakout baby this year uh
he's on tour and uh solidified that for
him and he's had a
great uh success record since we've been
working together
uh he did the hbo comedy wings at the
african-american film festival down in
miami which you won and
it's just been a great time just
figuring it out right and and kind of
being that person that you can call and
say hey
this is what i'm thinking about doing uh
i like to think of myself as more a
consultant and a career partner more
than a manager because most of my
clients uh
we're here for the long haul we have to
see it through and see it in completion
and kind of figure out where we can
navigate some of the things that we
can't control and then i just try my
best to uh give them as much attention
as i can while helping other people who
i know don't have a person or like
myself didn't really have formal
education
and you kind of want to pass on that
education so people know what to look
out for and you know how to navigate
that's pretty much
me in a nutshell
[Music]
what what year
was it when you started working with uh
earthquake
um this is my 10 year so
[Music]
2012 officially i guess you could say
2011. okay yeah i've i've been
uh february 1st was my 12 year comedy
anniversary so for
for comedians like me i mean basically
all i know is i'm like i gotta write a
lot i gotta perform a lot i gotta write
a lot i gotta perform a lot but like the
business side you know it's show
business you know it's it's two jobs
that we have so like what are some
common
like or like what like all right let's
let's let's take let's make this very
selfish all right
if you were to like work with me
you knowing kind of context for like you
and i know each other some like what
would you do working with me to kind of
i've been working in comedy 12 years i
have this podcast it's like i'm supposed
to be will ferrell right now what is
that
you know what i mean
i i have gratitude but it's like uh like
you know what what would you what would
you do
well the first thing is you have to
acknowledge that comedy has it the
hardest
um
that i feel like i can definitively say
just from moving around in other places
even in music and music is terrifying
it's super super hard but uh at least
when you make it you get some sense of
respect right in comedy you can make it
and there's still some places where like
yeah you made it over there buddy you
know you didn't make it
right here though you're like
what do i have to do so
it's
perspective where's your thought process
as a comp what do you want to do because
some people
see themselves in a place and we've got
to be honest about that so is it
you're not being able to perform
joel is that where the hiccup is you
know let's start with what the immediate
thing is some people say i can't get
into comedy clubs
and then it's you it's not that you
can't get into comedy clubs you don't
want to get into comedy clubs unless
it's on the weekend
you know so you're fighting for a
weekend now we have to think of
inventory let's do numbers you know i
break it down literally to a science
what's the capacity
what's the your ticket price so
can you sell a hundred tickets at twenty
dollars
by yourself
not what did the club advertise because
people feel well if they told them one
you know on the radio i was coming
you know that's taking into account what
the radio can sell but i'm asking you
can you put it on eventbrite do you have
that power if i just say i have joel
coming to my house how many of my
friends are coming
that's your power
did you have that power in high school a
lot of these comedians you have to look
at who are you as a person
do you have the power to bring people to
thanksgiving
are they saying is joel gonna be there
because joel's coming i'm coming are you
the cousin that comes you know to grab
my house and all the cousins come
because you're there
you have to hone in that power and if
that's a no and you don't naturally have
that then we have to be honest about
do you go into walmart and just peruse
the aisles because that's what you're
expecting people to do now
i'm just walking up and down and hoping
that joel pops up on the shelf and i say
i i'll try this
i have to be in walmart i have to have
the time i have to not be going in there
for another specific item
and that really
perspective wise in my experience helps
comics break it down into a business
and if that's too complicated for you
then you know you just want to be
responsible for the jokes
and if you just want to be responsible
for the jokes be honest about
how much you need to pay somebody to be
responsible for the things you don't
want to be responsible for
and that's where your investment in your
career goes
because when i'm out here working and
put you in a position to have an
opportunity that's where the writing and
the telling jokes and hole in the wall
comes
into play that's where the preparation
meets the opportunity but
everybody can't go get both you can't go
get an opportunity and prepare for it
right so what do you want me to do are
you hiring me to give you an opportunity
you've been preparing for or do you want
me to just be honest with you and say
even though you've been doing it for 12
years joel like you've been preparing to
do it for 12 years
you're like damn
you've been preparing to do it for 12
years so
you're where you are joel you where
you because in the old days with my dad
i'm sure you've heard that like you have
to put 20 years in comedy before so for
12 years you've been
eight
nine yeah
you know what i mean that's what you
were preparing so that way when 20 came
you're like
where's my sitcom
where's my movie so
it's not that it's wrong it's just
change when things change if you see
somebody who's been in it for three
years don't say hey
he skipped the line say hey what did he
do
yeah and that's social media like i mean
that's the you know and i've had desi
banks on here i've had chico you know i
mean all basically all your clients i've
had on here as well so it's like
it's uh that seems to be the new wave as
it's like you really that walmart aisle
shopping that's social media and you've
got to be in front of people and you've
got to have that following
and it's like it's a whole other skill
set beyond
i'm i i have that old school mentality i
think like that your dad comes from of
like just kill on stage just kill and
people will find you but it's like
social media it's like you know kill on
social media and then people will find
you
well you have to think joel you've been
in this 12 years where have you found
someone that made it
because they killed on stage
and i mean my father is
undeniably oh
to ever grab a microphone and my
childhood
memories come from
the fact that he's a closer he's a
natural disaster the show's over
after that you get what i'm saying oh
yeah
and that was the thing that i got to see
from a love perspective because as a
daughter you want that person
to win
you get what i'm saying but at the same
time from a business
standpoint i also saw
why i could never get him to come to my
college either
you know what i mean so there's a gap
that we missed in the college days that
i think people like kevin hart tapped
into
because he would go and circulate all
the colleges and then go to the arenas
you know we looked at the colleges of
you all don't have any money and i'm not
speaking to you about bills and real
life experiences right because
historically comedians could put a great
spin on real life issues and we didn't
always look at college kids as dealing
with real life issues you know so i
think there was a bit of a disconnect
between
this huge hbcu movement and focus on
that demographic that chico bean is a
part of a product of i'm sorry and uh
darren big baby bran is a part of you
get what i'm saying um osama bin drankin
he is huge at north carolina a t you've
got these comedians who
looked up to people like my dad right
but people like my dad didn't go to
college don't have that greek
um hbcu tie but are friends with dion
sanders and remember those days so it's
a different time where now maybe we can
integrate uh
live events into bowl games like they do
for roll tide and you know some of the
huge pwis who um have those budgets and
then kind of build something
that we remember from our memory of you
know the dl hubleys and cedric the
entertainers being the kings of comedy
we don't really have an opportunity to
become the kings of comedy just by
killing on stage and we were too young
to know that they didn't get the kings
of comedy just by killing on stage it
was they had agents who were like i have
this script you know bernie mac was
constantly like i have a show idea you
have dave chappelle his nickname was
pilot boy so this generation is
he's a phenomenon he's our great we love
him but if you were raised in this you
were like he was knocking on every
single door
even when he got on comedy central it
wasn't like
abc scandal revealed it was who's
watching that until the ratings you know
come out so i think
my original point was that it's a hard
business right and we've never seen
anybody make it just off of that so
if you know that
use the gen x mentality of smarter not
harder and still get on the microphone
never leave that because jay leno taught
us that yep no matter what
yep yeah always hermosa beach right yeah
yeah yeah
so
um that is going to be a constant always
say but you have to do more than that
and you have to do more than look at me
get your acting classes is your diction
there are you doing free viral videos if
there's social media
i'm glad you interviewed
somebody like desi banks you know he has
learned from tyler chronicles ronnie
jordan
um
you know darren big baby brand he did
his work
you know so i think he's different than
a social media person because dc young
fly did the same thing you got to get in
this thing and learn the craft right
then you have to still navigate the cold
rooms the non-sold out shows you know so
these guys
are still doing it but in a microwave
level still a meal still nourishment but
just
packaged differently and we all have to
take into account what we're all
acceptable to you know being affected by
yeah i'm feeling at this point
that
i'm i'm like
thinking where the most momentum is and
it feels like it's with like and what do
i have that no one else has it's like i
feel like this podcast is a good
opportunity and i've gotten a lot of
opportunities just from doing the
podcast where it's like it's a comedian
that i've then worked with or it's a fan
who's like hey i run this festival will
you come to this festival so i'm
starting to see
more organic opportunities just the more
i do this podcast so part of me feels
that building
this show up
to because i don't you know i mean not
to not to flex but
no one really has over 400 interviews
with the type of comedians you know you
know what you know what i'm saying so
it's like
getting more
and my mindset is like just create
create create keep moving forward keep
moving forward like i haven't even
looked back at like the breadth of work
and how to repurpose it and like be more
strategic with what i'm doing but i'm
i've given a lot of thought and i mean
i'm comfortable
being known
as like the podcaster joel byers and
then be able to kill on stage
when the opportunities come
and like
but i i think i'm at a point now i'm
more comfortable just going all in on
making this show great
instead of like okay well what's my
social media strategy and like what
skits am i gonna do and who do i
collaborate with i almost feel like this
podcast is kind of like an empty like an
an untapped market really that i just
have already put a lot of work into and
if i could find a way to be more
i don't know strategic about how i'm
doing it and the the moves i'm making
with it
that i feel like this could become like
the portal to like
that fame that i'm looking for
yeah i think you're on to something uh
you specifically resonate with
your guests differently and i can just
say that from my clients that you've
interviewed right um and that's that
oprah effect
you know how can you
get certain things out of people or have
certain type of conversations but you're
absolutely right the good part about
being a comedian and having a podcast is
it's easy for people to want to hear
your point of view on other things
and if you learned anything from you
know shout out to the fan 85 south yeah
yeah
podcast right
um
and that is the brainchild of carlos
miller you know who is
what we call the sensei the sensei yes
yes
um yes
and
being able to apply a thing if he's a
creator right so there's a podcast so
even
though he started it it's his brainchild
and he was able to navigate the recipe
now where the touring
um 85 south group is chico dc and carlos
right
um
we also have podcast deals with black
effects that's a separate deal
then there's an 85 stop media deal with
outback where we can tour with the live
podcast and then each three of those
people individually can still
go out independently or
collectively doing strictly stand up
that's not included in them
so
you get to have that same opportunity
once you see hey this is a podcast right
where is it going to go is it going to
go
in a podcast room where you're making a
deal like a joe rogan spotify situation
and then that
is your platform now like your billboard
to say come see me at the punchline come
see me at zany's in nashville because we
can see the analytics for the podcast
are great in nashville you know what i
mean and then it just gives you
um another open playing field to connect
the dots you know and then you'll
definitely find something like a little
code like a little podcast
mixed with you know a sponsorship
yeah
you know now my ticket sales every time
i put it up i don't even have to
uh carve out expenses for the radio
because i can advertise it on my podcast
so i'm my own advertising platform and
that's something 85 south has done
brilliantly just by building it up where
it's a platform that's a production
company where we can
advertise the people who um have helped
build it on that platform internally
without having to you know pay
radio or even
instagram to run an ad for so
yeah right now the show is
primarily
like aspiring and like working comedians
like the the audience is even though i
have interviewed like a cedric
entertainer and like jeff foxworthy and
like you know big name comedians
the audience is still primarily
uh like comedians essentially which is
dope and that's who the show is for but
i do i feel like there's a missing
there's something missing that like
connecting to the greater the bigger
comedy community of just comedy fans who
would come see a show you know what i
mean
i feel like that's like that's like the
next step for the show is figuring out
how to tap into that market
uh beyond like always serving comedians
first but i just
i don't think people love comedy more
than ever now and i think they like to
hear how the sausage is made which this
show is
but there's a disconnect right now
between like comedy fans and then it's
just being like comedians right now
maybe you look at
uh behind the scenes you know
where you can get something that fans
always wanted to know like what happened
you know
uh the t are you saying the t
we love t now if i had to come for hot
breath to find out what happened you
know with cedric the entertainer on that
one charlotte show or you know something
like that yeah i love to to see you know
you still get the education and maybe
the consumer learns how human comedians
are and
that's always a hard thing too once you
hit that thing
chico said it best about
fame is
nothing but having strangers feel like
they know you and people who know you
feel like you're a stranger you know so
it's
a balance you know so maybe if we get
more interviews
like you that can see oh just boxworthy
is a human person you know you'll
approach it differently when you see
them in the target
so it could almost be you coming from
like a branding and a pr background as
well it could almost be like
the show right now is positioned as like
comedy education so it's almost
positioning it more
as
i yeah something a little more like
generic or
like a comedy fan may hear learn comedy
from the pros and be like well that's
that's not
that doesn't apply to me like
you know so like
everything i've catered the show towards
is working in terms of comedians but
maybe it's just how it's positioned
that it's not accessible to comedy fans
because it doesn't resonate with them
maybe you do dropping jewels with joel
on hot breath
okay
consultation
drop in jewels with joel
that's just me talking you're saying
yeah you need well when you are
getting that specific t
that maybe that could be a segment you
get what i'm saying you're still doing
your
comedy prose you know
edition but maybe that's a different
layer of segment of
you know you're dropping some jewels
what is that that applies to everybody
whether it's
something i just want to know because
steve harvey wrote a whole book you know
act like a lady think like a man and
there were a lot of non-comedy fans who
took a lot of valuable information you
know so you'll get that audience if they
find someone who's
um
intellectual enough that they can
receive it from i think you'll open that
audience
so
how
how much does it cost
for
you
to
do all of that
listen that's a real consultation
oh that's a good idea how much do you
charge to to do that for everybody
no you're good no no i'm gonna use that
i would never want to come across as
appropriating
just kidding
[Laughter]
any of that you know no no no no you
know you're you're
super super loved no but it's stuff like
that that i love that
you know come off
giving that type of energy is what i
love to do just sitting around hanging
out right it's almost like would you
rather fifty thousand dollars are having
a dinner with oprah you know what i mean
that's the
the thing with me it's the
implementation that's the work it's the
time it's the accountability of joel
once we decide that this is what we're
doing i'm gonna see it through um until
people go wow
that podcast is the number one podcast i
didn't know they don't know you had over
interviews you were asking back when
people were booking weekends and saying
hey we can set up right here we can set
up at the hotel
they don't see that they only see you
know like 85 south we always joke uh
carlos miller is the only one who's
never missed an 85 south episode
you know
that work and dedication they see us and
say oh you sold out the arena in north
carolina it's like yeah but you didn't
see
the days when carlos was there um the
trap you know your app yeah yeah
you know doing what needed to be done so
that way you can say oh yeah that 85
south podcast that hosted the bet award
so
it's
not so much how much you charge but
how
bad do you want it how bad do you want
to see it through and what position can
i play if nothing else to be your
accountability partner and say hey joe
didn't we talk about this i have not
seen
this this this
so it's a process i say it typically
takes a good two years to get in tandem
minimum
yeah yeah of working together
yeah to start catching strides
yeah for the first year it's like
see what you do naturally because nobody
wants to be told what to do you know
about themselves
you know you don't want to come in and
say don't do that stop doing this and
change everything around and you feel
like you have a manager it's okay joel
what do you what do you like to do what
are you doing this for your wife your
baby what's this and i'm going to take
that same tenacity
and whether it's a green room writer of
he doesn't like dasani water too
i don't
tyler chronicles it's a bank
oh he's always yeah him and i both have
always been on the water game we both
love fire gang
you know but some people
i
we come from well i come from drinkers
you know my father's you know infamous
very 1738 now it's mcallen 18 but
uh before it was a specific liquor right
so in that same
breath that i would
say to a promoter about some remy martin
you know i need to know that you don't
drink
liquor and you won't drink any water if
the only one that's available is one
that you have a
disconnect with
you know what i mean so there's a
specific disconnect just knowing that
there's somebody that if you can vent to
that will make sure it's a priority
next
show even if that's tomorrow next week i
find gives you a little bit more space
to create
um and do what you need to do on stage
for the people who are going to say you
did a terrible show or a great show and
don't know it's because you're thirsty
sorry y'all
it's that dasani drip
it's a sunny drip you know
goodness
all right drink our non-designing water
now yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm actually
drinking water out of this
that's why i said that i know it was
water so i was like we'll drink our
dinner
yeah okay cool yeah i appreciate that
inside it because it is like you know 12
12 years in the game it's like and i'm
at a point the motivation is like being
able to
provide more stability for like my
family so if
me being me being able to
you know have the freedom to pursue this
this job and the volatility of it
especially during the pandemic and
whatnot i would like to take that
pressure off
my wife and her be able to do whatever
she wants type deal you know so um if
she wants i mean you know just giving
the option so i'm really focused on
stability right now and when i traced
i i gave a lot of thought to like
i looked at all like my favorite
comedians
and i like i tracked like how they got
to where they were like like how they
started to then where they got to where
they are
and then i was like well
what path would i want to follow or how
would i see myself getting there because
i do i do see myself in like will
ferrell movies and like i'm not aiming
for the middle here at all you know what
i mean and i never have but i do see
through that self-reflection the path
being
building this up building hot breath up
me being known
for hot breath but then that driving all
the other opportunities
and i'm i'm comfortable with that i had
to put my ego to the side and be like no
i'm a comedian maybe i do interviews but
like i'm cool at this point my career to
be like no i'm i'm cool being known for
hot breath and then they see me on stage
and they're like yo
all right you know
so i'm i'm cool with that so that's
where my mindset is around it
very recently
so it's just now like
yeah how getting to that next level like
you're saying of like well what does
that look like then who is the show for
if you're trying to get beyond comedians
and how can it be
positioned and branded in a way to where
it is like
the people
behind the punch lines as opposed to
like not just how do they write the
punch lines but really get into like the
story behind these comedians i'm
interviewing
and that's where your goal is your goals
is because you have to bring your own
audience we always think the audience
will come and it's really what comes
first the chicken or the egg right
is it if i'm properly advertised they
will come or if they will come anyway
will they properly advertise
you know what i mean so
you have to figure that out if you
already know who your audience is and
you wanted to expand those are the
people who pay
25 and two item minimums and stand
outside in the cold and
you know don't demand refunds and wait
six to eight weeks when they order your
merchandise on your website and it still
hasn't come yet you know and they're not
in the dms like where the hell is my
hoodie you know uh it'll get to that but
they have to be your people because your
people love you
for you you know and you wouldn't want
manufactured love in
any other instance so will pharaoh has
his people but
put yourself in a light that will make
people love you in a movie that they
love you know what i mean that's what
chris tucker did with friday and all
those staple or even rush hour you know
it's somebody i love in a movie that i
love so
it's it's the same thing and now
everyone's producing you have people who
are going
viral and famous from sundance film so
it's not the same as it was
let me go read off a paper for this
audition or this live tape i'm not gonna
get unless i'm with a big name agency
if you can act
that's your calling card on social media
you know what i mean there's casting
directors looking for the way that you
look just aesthetically your face
how you can
play younger and not older that's going
to benefit you but a casting director
needs to know that you're
available and you can read off of the
script
you know what i mean yeah yeah that
makes sense yeah
but as a as a as i'm if i'm being a
podcaster it's like they're not seeing
me
they're not seeing me in that light
they're seeing me as like an interviewer
asking good questions they're not seeing
me necessarily being funny or
entertaining you know
but if they go on this your social media
and they see you in a skit
i can see your range
true
you know what i mean those are the
separate checks like we talked about
earlier with the 85 and
chico bean comparison right you want to
be able to get multiple streams of
income anyway right for sure so if i
already have a podcast check i'm looking
for a podcast deal if i already know my
stand up i'm looking for where can i get
in these clubs
you know how can i leverage it but it
all goes to who is your audience for who
i don't know
you'll find out because they'll come
welcome okay you know and you'll know
but right now at least you know you're
pandering to comedians if you want
another audience
what do you do you go to a different
club
yeah oh oh
geralyn said free gyms
daryl and sims
and
hbcu maid said great interview
oh yeah
we've gotten some love out here
kp said fun and informative interview
michelle liked dropping jewels with joel
thanks michelle oh yeah yeah you're
saying do that every podcast or that's a
separate like you can but have it be you
know think about it with radio it's
breaking down and said
right right right now don't reinvent the
wheel comedians all of you you get what
i'm saying it's it's a thing ryan
seacrest had like the number one radio
segment
that they could sell the most
advertising to and it was called ryan's
roses and if i'm remembering it
correctly the bit was you would
i would call you and say joel i've got
free dozen roses
who do you want to send them to
and you would say oh send them to
natalia and then your wife will be like
well who the hell is
that would be the bit and it the idea on
radio is
with the old people russ parr and um you
have um tom joyner it's on a clock
you're going to tune in 10 till the hour
we're doing this right we're telling you
abc is dropping your favorite tv show at
8pm 7 central right i'm letting you know
you you need to let me know what's
happening
at what time
you're just letting me know what you're
doing and you're giving me an option but
if i say
i'm doing this at this time and you get
this
you give me a reason to meet you there
okay i mean i've started like i do these
weekly q and a's and then i on tuesdays
i do
like a a joke feedback hour
okay um on all on youtube channel like
i'm really trying to build a youtube
channel this year i feel like there's a
lot of momentum there
um
so yeah but it is all the q a and the
joke feedback hour are still
super like comedian specific you know
what i mean so
it's not tapping into that bigger
audience like a comedy fan is going to
be like oh let's go
see
new comics get joke feedback
well he will but you it's how you
advertise it that's where that marketing
comes into play right if you're doing a
consultation the way just my brain works
i'm like okay
if this is what you need to do let's
find a clip even out of this um
interview me and you were hap having
right something i've said
to other businesses
you take it out of excerpt
you headline it drop in jules withdrawal
you send them to the youtube
okay that seems like a great place and
then you're advertising it was like oh
what's chopping jewels with joel i don't
know but i went on this hot red podcast
and then they were talking about this
and then that and then i'm getting other
things and it might be a different
excerpt it might not be the whole
interview but it might be that part
where it's just 10 minutes of when
somebody was dropping jewels in a
continuous fashion you know most of us
go on tangents we start talking about
one thing and next you know we're in
real estate business by the end of it
[Laughter]
but it's all relevant i mean marquez
just said amazing nuggets dropped
and um
michael says
wow she knows her stuff great interview
and justin fleming lovely listening to
you natalia very insightful
no thank you uh savvy comic says we love
you joel
so yeah i mean there's yeah the the
people that rock with the show rock with
it heavy and you even said that with
like people who've heard like chico's
interview like out on the road they'll
reference the interviews so like people
that find the show rock with it heavy
um so i do need to show gratitude for
that but i'm also thinking of like you
know we're
we're not chop liver here
you know like we
we we deserve
you know all the work we're putting in
like you know we deserve
to have that recognized on a on a big
level you know
and now you have to make it easier it's
almost like i
the example i gave you about the casting
director right we put too much pressure
on a casting director to come and find
little old you
you get what i'm saying make it easy for
them you have this space plaster it
right you have to make sure you always
have a visual some podcasts you can just
listen to but with your face that's
commercial you need to make sure it's
always being shown hot breath is amazing
right but they need to know who you are
people know me as boss lady because a
lot of my clients that's what they refer
to me as but even for a branding
uh
point you know people still have to know
your name
you know it's respectful
but i'm not out here telling oh can you
call me boss lady it's a preference like
a sign of respect you know because i'm
gonna get something done but
they still need to know your name
my name is natalia your name is joel
what we do
is going to follow with the people who
are fans of ours they're going to tell
people who you are
you just need to say oh that's me
okay
so what uh what i'm what i'm leaving
here with
for
neck as you talked about ideas but then
the execution behind them so it seems
like the execution would be
perhaps testing out these dropping
jewels
with joel
where it's like something dope is said
in an interview
and it's basically
me talking about it and maybe like
weaving in the interview as i'm talking
about it
but with the mindset of like how
how to market this
and package this as something
interesting to like comedy fans in
general and not just like comedians
yeah well not even comedy fans it's
people there's some comedy is subjective
i can be a fan of you and not be a fan
of your stand-up comedy
i can be a fan of your podcast
and not be
you know a fan of you know your
commentary
don't force people to put
don't force your consumers into boxes
let them choose
they might not want to sit through your
whole podcast that they might want to
come and
take some useful information there might
be people who have never heard your
podcast at all who are on here because
i'm on here right right and now they're
going to go back make it easy for them
to find the gold
you get what i'm saying go and say oh if
i know i have an urban audience today
let me go to some of the things that i
think would resonate that's not to say
td jakes only preaches to black churches
you get what i'm saying but
i need to still find value in what he
says no matter what the audience is
so find the value and the audience will
find
what you put out if that makes sense if
you say hey
this is dropping jewels with joel and
you did a 10-minute compilation of
things that you valued and you just said
something at the beginning here are some
of my most favorite memories of our
podcast um and these are the most
impactful things tell me what your
favorite thing is you post the
compilation you start a dialogue you
might have missed some things somebody
might say oh my favorite nugget was this
now you've already got episode two and
worked
i like the compilation
uh yeah i like like the top most
impactful like quotes from like 400
interviews like
i i yeah i like that route like doing
one of those 400 because you have 400
just do
from 21 from 19 from
october you know what i mean oh yeah
that's what i meant like top five or two
yeah yeah not like yeah not all of them
but like starting there giving them like
the cream of the crop and then them
telling me what they believe the cream
of the crop is and creating more off of
that
yeah i like that i like that i'm excited
about that format and then you can use
that as a marketing tool with your
social media to drive to your youtube
page and your podcast just by taking
those
those um
excerpts so that way you don't feel like
you need to go out and shoot new
material comics i always feel like oh i
need to shoot today i'm like your old
stuff works music people do it all the
time you play an old record and we're
still
jam that has nothing to do
with me not going to the concert and
buying a ticket
throwback thursday is helpful throw it
back they give you the hashtags use them
flashback friday
use it flashback to the chico bean
interview hashtag
dropping jewels with joel now you got a
hashtag hey we got a hashtag out of this
that's still free still free game
i did my joe scheisti dance
i don't know what i'm doing
water gang out here okay
i love it well thank you um wow thank
you so much this was incredible um
yeah all right like you i mean you're
yeah i knew this was going to be dope
and this this was so smooth too it just
it just
seeps out of you all this this gold and
i appreciate you uh being able to share
your time and energy with us honestly
i'm a huge fan of what you're doing and
i've i watch from afar i see the moves i
see the tours
i see it and i'm i'm a fan of it and i'm
inspired by it so um
for
do you have any like closing i know i
had bob kirk asked something about like
how important is social media and what
socials would you concentrate on
um
please can i can i address the social
media thing that is the biggest thing
i've always i have to say
to artists
everywhere
businesses i think are a little bit
different but social media is nothing
but a billboard
it is a billboard business card
slash resume
what you need to be focusing on is what
it looks like when someone likes myself
comes to your page
it's a reflection of you if you've got
old flyers old hole in the wall stuff
that makes me think that you're not
ready for this big tour up here because
you're still advertising somewhere you
wish you could stop playing
so if you don't want to play for 10
lemon pepper wings and a strawberry
daiquiri
put it in your story or at least take it
down after you've played it because it
is a reflection of you i'm not saying
don't go get your money
go get your money but don't expect me to
come pay you top dollar or have one of
my friends pay you top dollar or me as a
manager be able to to convince a
promoter to pay you top dollar if right
here on your social media it says you
went down here for two dollars and a
coca-cola
focus on that before you focus on
following why would somebody want to
follow you you got this two dollar
coca-cola flyer on here
why
i don't want to see it and i know you
so i'm out of respect muting it
and i'm missing the good stuff because
i'm sick of the things because
everyone's like stay busy stay busy no
quality over quantity if you need to
stay active go live regularly
but your posts need to be a reflection
of you your personality your business
or how much money
if we can start there i think we'll be
better but don't
whatever platform showcases that the
best is what you need to focus on if you
are alive like big baby is live he is a
live character
his tick tock goes crazy
you know what i mean so if that's
something you're into where you're
wanting to do acting tick tock is for
you
you can act out your favorite scenes you
want to be in movies that's where you
should focus your energy on tick tock
why would you focus your energy on
social media if
if you say hey joel i put um a t-shirt
on your your website right and you
didn't sell any
that lets you know people who are buying
things aren't coming to your page
so what makes you think me putting you
at the state farm arena in atlanta is
going to change
those same 10 people buying a t-shirt
versus
you giving them you
yo
are they coming to be entertained are
they coming to get information
some comics post flyers and you can't
even read what city it's in
i'm like where are you going to be
you're just worried about being
advertised it says comedy explosion we
can't see where we have no idea
are you posting it so be intentional
what's your purpose for writing to
inform to persuade let's take it to
english
the purpose of being social on social
media to entertain
to inform
to have a platform
then you should know which one you
should be using
you know so what do i know
i love how like turnt you got right
there like you're like let's just
address this really quick
my dms go crazy listen i'm single
because they are blocking
the shots that could be shot
with these frivolous
help me out boss lady i need to get my
followers up how do i get my followers
up buy them
that's how
you want followers purchase them
if you get them 11 million tomorrow joe
that does not mean i have more
opportunities for you mm-hmm
so stop it with asking people it's not
social media i can't say this
definitively
outside of an advertising deal
that
was based on analytics have i ever done
a deal for any of my clients based on
their social media
huh
i don't go into a negotiation saying
chico bean has
2.5 million on
instagram why would i do that they're
just gonna want him to advertise the
show
chico beans followers are not purchased
and they are not accustomed to us
pandering to them so why would we start
they're following him because they know
when he has on an outfit
they're gonna see it
oh he's always flexing on him oh with
the look down with the look at that
look
it's kind of look down
always the fresh kicks
always now you know darren brand
waking big nation yup
let him go live
they will
go on smoke break so quick
[Laughter]
you know what i mean so you have to let
people know but the people on instagram
are not looking for that on his tick
tock
the people on tick tock aren't going on
instagram going where is that
you know what i mean
but he'll post something from tick tock
you'll be like i wish i was on tick tock
he probably has more of these thank you
for sharing on instagram
uh-huh so that's that's the idea you
want don't get into the game of how many
followers you have because they're going
to expect those people to buy tickets
and i'll leave it at that however many
followers you have you need to know how
many of those people will purchase
something
very much something purchase something
twenty dollars
a hoodie
her chest something
so what would you would you recommend
for like me personally is like mixing in
the podcast and my comedy if like people
are coming for one thing
it's like
is it like picking a lane and just going
super deep on that one thing so they
know when they're coming to the channel
they're getting
uh like a laugh or like a skit or
stand-up clip versus like
me like being educational on the podcast
it seems like i need to pivot away from
being so honed in on the educational
aspect of the show no you can but you
just have to know that there are a lot
of intellectuals who go to
youtube
for insight
right you need to be on their radar are
you in the areas where
they're
drinking from the fountain of motivation
does your podcast pop up as a suggested
video when they're going and seeing some
of the people that they consider mentors
right right where you are in social
media is where nobody wants to learn
they don't even want to read
why are you trying to educate me
somewhere where i'm trying to you know
[Laughter]
for the look down the line
the look back
i want to go find these shoes he has on
so
you can get our attention but it's going
to be quick that's why i'm telling you
the nuggets if i'm scrolling and i see
something that speaks to my psyche
and i'm like oh i want more of that i'm
going to go on youtube and put in hot
breath where is that and i'm gonna
listen
it's how we listen to our pastors that's
how we listen to
you know some of our uh
like spiritual advisors you know
everything comes from youtube but we
pass that information through
conversation
so you want to be in those rooms where
someone's saying you know what you need
i where did you get that oh i learned
that on hot breath
really yeah it was a dope interview with
blah blah blah
who cares who you were interviewing it's
what am i taking away from it as soon as
you said jackpot worthy i didn't even
know you did that interview
i'm a fan
i'm gonna go watch it
so i'm like ooh he always says things
that are perspective provoking for me so
i'm like ooh i know you said something
oh
bet
all right
so if you're watching this and you're
not subscribed subscribe to the youtube
channel
there we go look at that see call to
action
um but uh thank you wow yeah yeah this
this i knew it's gonna be dope but you
you've exceeded expectations you've done
it
oh thank you boss lady nay is there is
there anything um
anything else you want the world to know
jen weeks said 10 lemon pepper wings she
really liked that one
um it's a thing
oh big facts yeah that's the thing
telling joe it is i've been there we
came up from the mud y'all
mm-hmm what did you have your were they
buffalo we got this from the mud
i like i like naked wings you know i'm
i'm a minimalist
okay
let's see you're on too many urban
people so you got to get them fried hard
that's good oh for sure yeah yeah yeah
it's a cr it's crackling for sure yeah
yeah
well is how can people um
check uh justin asked if you have a
youtube channel like yeah where can
people follow you and reach out to you
and be like we love you this was amazing
you can find me on
instagram at boss lady nay in a e
boss lady spelled traditionally i have
made a commitment that i am going to try
to share more
um you know insight so look out
on my instagram and try to
you know drop some jewels with joel in
the future hey
i mean they're not out there right now
i'm telling you you know i go straight
pi private investigator on my guests
like i go deep on them to whether i've
had some guess are you the feds they're
like how do you
so
um i i tried to go there and there's
nothing and you are a well of wisdom
that i think i think the world really
needs to hear so yeah anything i can do
on my end to help with that i'm here but
i'm i'm excited to hear that you're
wanting to kind of start doing that more
yeah
i am uh launching boss talks if you will
you know
giving some insight there's a lot of
business owners who just don't have a
person to ask you know just like you
said like for somebody like me
what would you advise you know and then
just try to give wisdom i'm one of those
people that can learn from other
people's mistakes uh but i had to make
them because everyone hid their mistakes
so
it's you know i'm happy to share my
songs like please don't
don't be me i tell my little sister
we're all the time like you have an
older sister he's so much better than me
i'll tell you everything i did
because it's not on google so you're
gonna have to tell it yeah
it's not on google
you know but yeah it's important to let
people know so that way they can see but
you know anytime happy to to help and
happy to be here but check me out on on
instagram and we'll get something going
on
so if you enjoyed boss lady nade go send
her a dm slide in there
very politely and let her know she
dropped a lot of jewels today dropping
gems dropping jewels with joel we're
gonna do it i won't let you down
please don't
all right
have a good day hot breath verse thanks
for watching everyone we love you all so
much
[Music]
you